hey everybody is Charlie we got a
preview of the new Iron Man armors that
are gonna debut during Avengers 4 so we
got to do a breakdown of that as the
clip implies Pepper Potts is going to be
wearing armor we know what that looks
like now and iron man's gold armor based
on some old concept art there's a new
brand of that Spider Man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
they just released a concept design of
Iron Man's Civil War armor with gold
arms they didn't say why they didn't use
it but because of the concept art that
we've seen for his mark 85 armor during
Avengers 4 with the gold arms this is
just a much better example of what it's
going to look like albeit it'll be his
infinity war armor this much more
streamlined the nanotech it looks like
one bonded piece of armor instead of a
bunch of different pieces so not only is
this a really badass figure this is from
Hot Toys that's the reason why we have
this thank you to Hot Toys for giving us
these really detailed looks at some of
the armors that you don't necessarily
get from the movie get these really cool
up-close shots this also remind you how
much more evolved his infinity war armor
is the previous ones because we didn't
get any armor a shot so it's a little
hard to compare the infinity war armor
is really meant to be like a second skin
it's not full-blown endosymbiont have
the symbiote so Iron Man hasn't gotten
that idea in his head yet he was
inspired by the way the symbiotes work
to create a version of the suit that
works a little bit more like liquid
metal but if they were to do that in a
movie it would look almost exactly the
same way the nanotech armor does where
it just forms around him so it's not
quite as big of a payoff but the other
thing that people have been freaking out
about this morning is a full-blown look
at Pepper Potts rescue armor from the
movie we had an idea that she was gonna
be wearing special armor because there
were a bunch of pictures that Gwyneth
Paltrow had posted naturally there's the
interview with Colbert where she talks
about having dots all over her with her
fighting CG creations so very clearly
that was gonna be some big action scene
probably not gonna be doing that without
the aid of some armor but she also
posted shots of her from behind the
scenes last year in her trailer where
she's wearing a unitard like Mark
Ruffalo or any of the other motion
capture actors would wear so we had a
pretty good idea for what was happening
we didn't really know what the story was
gonna be that was gonna demand that she
put armor on like
but the threat will be or what it would
actually wind up looking like because in
the comics is actually read but the
whole idea is is that it debuted during
2009 and there was all these jokes about
Pepper Potts
being in the armor so finally Matt
Fraction made it more literal and had
Tony surprise make her a suit of armor
his whole thing is that he can't stop
building crazy suits of armor so of
course it would make sense that he would
do that for her at some point but the
comic book version of the suit is really
just designed for emergency search and
rescue but it doesn't really have any of
the crazy extra gear that you would find
in war machines armor or even Iron Man's
armor use the Iron Man gets the most
advanced version of the suit war machine
gets whatever the latest hand-me-down is
it looks like he always has the most
weaponry just because of the way his
suit comes together but for the most
part the nanotech suit that Iron Man's
wearing during infinity war can form
almost any of the weapons that war
machine is using so technically Iron Man
has the most weaponry but the suit is so
advanced that the nanotech just forms
those weapons on the fly when he wants
them the way the lines on this look it
looks like it's a derivative of the
infinity war nanotech armor so it's
probably just a couple small pieces like
say even the iron spider armor which is
also a little bit of nanotech that
attaches to her then the rest of it
forms out of whatever that small pieces
so whereas during Iron Man 3 she was
just wearing his regular suit with all
the normal stuff that it could do this
armor is probably specifically designed
for things that Tony would feel like
Pepper would be doing if she actually
needed something like this so while they
might add some extra cool stuff on top
of the comic book rescue armor I don't
think that it has any of the crazy
weaponry that Iron Man's infinity war
armor has but I think the whole idea is
is that because this is a swan song for
a lot of the big characters and even
though she might appear in future movies
it's meant to be a big bookend for her
they're giving her a couple cool moments
during one of the really big CG battles
that maybe takes place on earth I don't
really see her going into outer space
we'll talk about that in a second but
because her character isn't like the
biggest character ever with a few
exceptions when Ironman is around just
expect her to get a couple really badass
moments during one of the CG battles the
reason why there might be a battle on
planet earth is because the trailer
descriptions that we've been getting say
that Thanos
mine's up back on planet Earth in an
alley with his sword so at some point in
the movie maybe he fights The Avengers
and it becomes an homage to that
original Battle of New York Avengers
Assemble moment only it stano's that
they're fighting and there's all this
collateral damage and that's why Pepper
Potts would need special armor a lot of
you will point out though wasn't their
whole conversation at the beginning of
infinity war about Pepper Potts not
being super hot on the idea of Ironman
putting the arc reactor back in his
chest and living that life this is the
deleted longer version of that scene so
it's them talking about the wedding
talking about potentially having kids in
Ironman settling down not using the
armor anymore and getting rid of the arc
reactor so you woke up and not sure we
were expecting yes I did dream about it
was so real if you want have a kid I'm
glad you brought this up because it's
nothing it's just a housing unit for
nanoporous it's not helping no it's not
a you don't need that I know I had the
surgery I'm just trying to protect us
see trusses and that's it just in case
there's months from the closet instead
of you know
you know me so well we don't even have a
wedding date yet
you set Argos 27th that's the decoy date
because this media circus that's going
on is driving me crazy okay this is me
on edge I'm sorry because I'm trying to
keep all the pictures out of the paper
and off the internet so your weddings
not ruined no one's working harder than
remember that kid from TMZ do you have
me trade paint with on the FDR Drive
well I got a case against me now that's
my fault yeah it's your fault lose him
HAP lose him have like the Godfather's
really funny the big quote there you
should have shirts in your closet not
suits of armor so they're trying to
foreshadow his potential future but that
was obviously before the snap inning
before half of the universe died so I
think part of the reason why he would
have gone ahead and made armor for her
is it because he comes back from that
he's broken and you had the version of
Ironman that we're gonna be saying
during most of Avengers four until they
eventually saved the universe and fix
everything then he can finally do what
he told Pepper Potts he was gonna do oh
this thing here like is he's tapping it
talking to her I don't really need this
it's just a housing for nano parts this
is here just in case if they can pay off
that Iron Man 3 moment where he threw
the arc reactor into the bay like he has
his moment where he gets married to
pepper and makes it seem like he's gonna
settle down until some big universe
altering event comes in a future
Avengers movie and they need to pull him
out of the mothballs regardless of what
happens to him at the end of the movie I
think that Robert Downey jr. is an actor
will always be happy to come back and
lend his voice or lend his appearance
just depending on the level of severity
I think they would save him for a really
big surprise like the Captain America
surprise during spider-man homecoming it
was just a funny moment but it was still
really really cool let me know in the
comments that what do you think about
Pepper Potts rescued armor what's gonna
happen is is will probably get some more
concept art and teasers for the other
characters new looks and their new
weapons in the next couple of months
we're getting really close to that
trailer dropping so if we hear anything
more about that I will totally do a
video about it congratulations strange
planet you're the giveaway winner from
my last big video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here to learn
about how Marvel already introduced
mutants in the MCU and click here to
learn why they cancelled iron fist and
Luke
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]